Ja heute mal wieder ein whatsapp themenvorschlag vielen dank ihr seid der hammer es geht
Um die kuriosesten und krassesten zahlen, des weltraums wir klären. Fragen wie gibt es mehr sandkörner auf der erde oder mehr sterne, im universum
auf welchem planeten ist die windstärke mit 1600 kilometern pro stunde
Am stärksten und auf welchem planeten sind wir menschen
Am leichtesten also angeber wissen zum staunen jetzt bei klicks und science fiction
Herzlich willkommen und wie ihr zu whatsapp kommt dass der vater am ende des videos
Platz sieben wie groß ist das universum wie kurs ist es die antwort niemand weiß es ja tut mir leid
Da fängt schon mal schlechter aber ich will euch jetzt nicht dumm sterben lassen einig ist es ganz logisch das universum ist ja
13,8 milliarden jahre alt da sicher nicht schneller als mit lichtgeschwindigkeit fortbewegen kann müsste es einen maximalen durchmesser von
27,6 milliarden haben aber das stimmt auch nicht denn es gibt etwas das sie schneller
Als licht fortbewegen kann ja hat denn der krachten die ganze zeit gelogen nein beides ist richtig wie kann das sein
Ja das was sich schneller bewegt als licht ist eigentlich nicht etwas es ist der raum selbst das universum
dehnt sich nämlich schneller als mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
Aus wenn wir was berücksichtigen dann wissen wir zumindest eines wie weit wir in jede richtung blicken können und das sind
46,6 milliarden lichtjahre also das universum dass wir sehen können hat einen durchmesser von
93,2 milliarden lichtjahren ob allerdings dahinter noch etwas ist das wissen wir leider nicht platz 6 der saturn besteht zu
96 prozent aus wasserstoff vielleicht wissen einige von euch dass der saturn ein gasplanet ist und bis auf vier prozent aus
Wasserstoff besteht er hat eine so geringe mittlere dichte dass er wohlauf wasser
Schwimmen würde er ist der äußerste planet mit dem bloßen auge sichtbar und war den menschen deswegen schon vor der erfindung des fernrohrs
Bekannt zudem ist der saturn auch der planet mit dem krassesten wind die windstärken in seiner atmosphäre erreichen bis zu
1600 kilometern pro stunde außerdem ist der saturn etwa
Neuneinhalb war so weit von der sonne entfernt wie die erde und somit braucht er für einen orbit
Um die sonne extrem lang eine umkreisung der sonne auf dem rad uhren dauert
30 jahre auf der erde platz fünf wie viele sterne gibt es eigentlich
Im weltall mehr als sandkörner auf der erde
Weil man noch nicht einmal weiß wie groß das universum ist weiß man auch nicht ganz sicher wie viele sterne es tatsächlich da draußen gibt
Aber es gibt schätzungen nach. Denen es eine quad region sterne sind also eine eins mit 24 0
Vor allem wenn man das mit der anzahl der geschätzten sandkörner auf der erde vergleicht eine studie kommt nämlich auf eine zahl von nur sie
millionen und 500 milliarden lächerlich also im vergleich
zu den sternen
Und es ist ja zu wenig sand hier auf der erde ist droht ja eine
Weltweite sand krise platz vier ein tag auf der venus dauert länger als ein venus
Ja
Jetzt wird es ein bisschen komplizierter
234 erdentage dauert einen tag auf der venus und ist damit tatsächlich länger als ein venus ja dass nur
225 tage dauert aber wie kann das sein
Erst einmal unterscheidet sich die venus gar nicht so sehr von der erde sie ist zwar ein bisschen kleiner hat aber eine ähnliche dichte
Und eine etwas kürzere umlaufzeit, um die sonne doch ihre oberfläche ist extrem. Heiß mit bis zu 500 grad celsius
Heiß, genug um sogar blight schmelzen zu lassen jetzt zurück zur eigentlichen frage sondern 25 tage beträgt die mittlere umlaufzeit der
Venus um die sonne doch die eigenen rotation um die eigene achse die dauert länger nämlich
234 er tage und so kommt es
dass ein tag auf der venus ein bisschen länger dauert als ein jahr ein kleiner fun fact nach oben
Drauf die eigene rotation der venus läuft degen setzt sich zu den meisten anderen planeten
Im sonnensystem und auf der 3 zwischen erde und mond ist sehr viel platz auch wenn der mond in super
Vollmondnächten wie am neujahrstag 2018 so hell und groß wirkt der trabant ist doch eine ganze ecke von der erde entfernt zu diesem zeitpunkt beispielsweise
359 1000 kilometer aber der abstand marie irrt wenn der mond auf seiner elliptischen bahn die maximale distanz erreicht ist der 400
5000 kilometer von der erde entfernt und dann würden tatsächlich alle anderen acht planeten unseres sonnensystems
Zwischen mond und erde passen das ist echt nicht ohne diese strecke wenn man sie mit einem
Normalen flugzeug zurücklegen würde wenn es ginge bräuchte man, mit zwischenlandung und tankstopps ganze
20 tage knappe zwei tage dauert es dagegen lediglich die erde am äquator. Zu umrunden platz zwei
Fußabdrücke auf dem mond halten sich ewig vielleicht wisst ihr ja auf dem mond gibt es kein wetter und das heißt
Im mondstaub sind immer noch die fußspuren von neil armstrong und buzz aldrin
Zu finden sie könnten quasi einfach nur mal kurz um die ecke verschwunden sein und gleich wieder
Auftauchen ja anders als hier auf der erde werden spuren auf dem mond weder von wind noch warmwasser verwischt sie halten sich
Millionen von jahren nur ein mitglied der zufällig genau an diese stelle an dieser stelle ein trifft der könnte sie
Verschwinden lassen aber die wahrscheinlichkeit ist groß dass ihre fußabdrücke
unsere zivilisation
Überdauern und meine absolute lieblingsstadt diät einfach mal ab auf dem mars wir berichten ja immer wieder mal über den mars denn viele experten
als
Erdähnliche zeichnen eines ist dort aber sicher ganz anders als auf der erde unser körpergewicht nämlich und das hat mit der schwerkraft zu tun die
Uns zur oberfläche hin zieht das wissen wir aber noch
Aus dem physikunterricht die größer die masse eines objekts umso größer ist auch die gravitation waren auf dem saturn und jupiter die
Beschleunigung also bei uns heißt das der erdbeschleunigung 9,81 meter pro sekunde, im quadrat
Höher ist als auf der erde wegen der dort viel mehr als hier einen 70 kilogramm schwerer mensch würde auf dem jupiter
175 gramm wiegen anders dagegen auf dem mars wenn man auf der erde also
70 kilogramm wien sind es auf dem mars nur noch drei achtel davon also gute 26 kilogramm, baby
Ich bin auf dem mars ja wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema mars besiedlung
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfährt
er von mir vor allen andern vom neuesten video täglich garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion vom tricks und mitmachen und
mir themen vorschlagen wie hier zum beispiel oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert und zur begrüßung
Gibt es noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken 1000 raketen zum mars ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran